reprise du bois de la sécurité
aujourd'hui avec une table ronde
consacrée aux relations police justice
en présence du ministre de l'intérieur
et le garde des sceaux une réunion dans
un contexte tendu on va voir tout cela
avec antoine boitel de la rédaction web
de notre chaîne tout de suite crt sur le
web
[Musique]
antoine boitel bonjour on gagnait on
avait un peu oublié le bouvau de la
sécurité c'est vrai c'est finalement le
retour des tables rondes 1 au ministère
de l'intérieur avec un programme qui a
changé et la danse de la participation
d'eric dupond-moretti
quel est l'état d'esprit du côté des
policiers alors effectivement le bol
sécurité avait dû s'arrêter pour des
raisons sanitaires puis les
organisations syndicales avait
finalement annoncé qu'elles suspendaient
leur présence après les deux meurtres
qui ont délié donc la police nationale
fin avril et début mai on sourdine la
colère monte déjà puis elle a éclaté
carrément le 19 mai sous les fenêtres de
l'assemblée nationale lors du
rassemblement intersyndical et le
syndicat alliance a d'ores et déjà
annoncé pour savoir qu'il maintenait ses
propos tenus lors du rassemblement par
la voix de son secrétaire général fabien
vanhemelryck à savoir je cite le
problème de la police c'est la justice
les syndicat synergie officiers qui est
donc aussi associé alliance assure que
je cite pour sa part le garde des sceaux
ne va pas passer une bonne matinée
donc on sent l'ambiance électrique qui
on peut rappeler à ce titre que les
syndicats de police pour leur part et il
anticipe déjà les élections
professionnelles qui ont lieu l'année
prochaine
donc il cumule aussi un peu les
déclarations un peu musclées depuis
quelques semaines pendant ce temps là
d'autres syndicats plus mesuré que j'ai
pu interviewer pour ce cet article à
l'instar de l'unsa police ou du
synapates où on semblait plus ouvert au
dialogue avec avec le gouvernement à
l'administration
donc finalement le beauvau peut à
nouveau avoir lieu mais avec un
changement de programme effectivement
puisqu'on est passé de cette table ronde
son maintien de l'ordre à une table
ronde sur les rapports avec le torino
autorités judiciaires à cette question
qui sera au coeur des débats de la table
ronde aujourd'hui comment simplifier et
moderniser et clarifier les relations
entre police nationale gendarmerie
nationale et la justice pour garantir un
traitement de la délinquance de masse
plus efficace et plus rapide
alors du côté du gouvernement et de
l'administration qu'elle est
l'état d'esprit à la proche de ce beau
mot selon mes sources et un certain
secrétaire général de ce syndicat qui
est connu pour avoir la langue bien
pendue notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
qui a tenté de s'en prendre à
l'institution judiciaire lors d'une
réunion avec les ministres à matignon
il ya quelques jours de cela et s'est
fait sévèrement recadré par eric dupond
moretti qui étaient présents dans la
pièce en personne et je cite le sénat la
source qui m'a parlé de cette réunion il
m'a dit le collègue le camarades
syndicalistes s'est fait torpiller en
direct chez castex donc on peut en
déduire que si les ministres de la
justice et de l'intérieur font mine de
préparer ou on fait mine de préparer ce
beauvau dans la concorde avec des photos
sur twitter etc
ils sont également prêts à défendre la
réforme de la justice qui sont en train
de porter et l'institution judiciaire
elle même qui inquiète s'il venait à
l'idée d'un syndicaliste x ou y de les
attaquer devant les caméras parce qu'il
faut le rappeler le bon goût est filmée
et diffusée en direct sur les réseaux
sociaux ce matin donc l'ambiance
s'annonce électrique pour ce beau sur
les rapports police gendarmerie et
justice
mais on peut aussi imaginer aisément que
personne ne sortirait grandi d'une
cheminée en direct entre les grands
syndicats et le garde des sceaux par
exemple donc sans boule de cristal
disons qu'il est probable que les
escarmouches il est resté marié reste
dans les limites du minimum syndical
comment merci beaucoup antoine boitel je
rappelle on peut vous lira notamment à
propos de ce bourg de lacq sécurité sur
notre site
rt france point tv